you wronged me you're gonna have to
catch me come flash infamy here Tuesday
October 6th
hey youtubers its charlie sound the
alarm there is new flash season 2
footage it's not the official trailer
it's just a promo but we do get to see
one of the new characters so here we go
if you didn't recognize him right away
this is atom smasher from the comics
which is interesting because he had a
really big Justice Society run early on
that Geoff Johns Road on which also
brought in Vandal Savage is a big bad at
a certain point it's almost like the
flash arrow in legends of tomorrow are
doing just a society without calling it
just the society we also see a flash
signal like a la bat signal and Captain
Cold and in a rather ambiguous fight
scene he could be trying to help Grant
Gustin this this could be all in the
same context from the same episode or it
could just be from some other scene they
had the real task of selling Captain
cold as an antihero so he actually has
to work with team flash a couple times
before he goes on legends of tomorrow
and not in like the backstabby way that
he did last season so here was the
original casting description for add a
Smasher and because you don't see his
face the actor that they cast is Adam
Copeland the edge from WWE I know
everyone's thinking about WWE this
weekend because Stephen Amell is going
on SummerSlam it's actually being hosted
by Jon Stewart from The Daily Show but
the way the TV show is is bringing atom
smasher on they described him one of the
most powerful enemies we encountered
this season atom smasher has come to
Central City to kill the flash his
incredible strength and ability to grow
to enormous size makes him more than a
match for the flash and the entire STAR
Labs team will have to come together to
find a way to defeat him the name of the
promo was catch me if you can so
obviously Barry Allen's gonna have to
run around fast enough so that atom
smasher can't wrap his hands around him
if he did that he's so strong but you
just see like the Flash's head go
popping off I suppose in that scenario
the flash could vibrate so fast that he
would vibrate through atom smashers hand
but I'm eager to see the TV show tries
to do that the weird thing though is
that the Justice Society team the atom
smasher was on when he was a hero was
Jay Garrick's team but here it looks
like they're still on earth one earth
one is our earth the one that we saw in
season one earth two won't be something
we'll see till season two and if I
haven't said it before Jay Garrick is
coming from earth 2 but going all the
way back in the comics when atom smasher
first appeared his name was nucleon he's
the god son of the Golden Age atom the
person who is the Adam before rape
Ray Palmer took the mantle from El Prat
he was born a metahuman he just has
control over his molecular structure
that allows him to grow in size he can
get denser he can shrink down the really
crazy thing about his power is is that
as he grows he's able to maintain
constant density like he doesn't get
less dense as he gets bigger which is
not the case for ant-man over in the
Marvel Universe but in order for atom
smasher to be able to do that his bones
break and regrow like that's part of his
ability so as he's growing bigger just
imagined it being the most painful thing
ever because he's not a villain in the
comics but I'm wondering is is if they
bring him on as a villain in the flash
TV show and then he ends up being a hero
by the end of the season with whether or
not he comes back on he might just be a
one-off appearance plastique was a good
example of someone they just brought on
for a very brief period then killed off
so hopefully they don't kill atom
smasher off but let me know what do you
guys think about this and what do you
think about the flash signal I'm
expecting a lot of Batman jokes from
Cisco Batman jokes without actually
saying the word Batman as for actual
trailer they might actually post
something next week during the Vixen
premiere maybe something that's like a
full minute long but as for that an
arrow I'm expecting the full trailers to
actually drop in the next couple weeks
if not during the Vixen premiere next
week which is actually next Tuesday I'll
remind everyone it might be the week
after that just to mention some cool
arrow news to Paul Blackthorne the actor
that plays Quentin Lance held up a Star
City police badge so arrow is officially
doing Star City I'll be interested to
see how they explained the rebranding in
the context of the show like how how all
the citizens of Starling city are just
gonna be like okay let's just change the
name of our city all of a sudden it's
gonna be a lot of fun though you guys
have no idea they're bringing some
awesome people onto the flash and arrow
this year I'm really excited about
damian darhk-- on arrow so why does wait
for that stuff to post you can click
here to learn all about Constantine
coming on arrow season 4 they're gonna
be resurrecting Sarah Lance and you can
click here to learn about some of the
new characters coming to the flash
season 2
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow